what's going on everybody it's warren
and welcome back to the cosmic wonder
where we talk all things marvel and
everything relating to the marvel
cinematic universe and yesterday we got
the
sixth episode of wanda vision finally
getting that famous halloween episode
that marvel has been teasing us since
before even getting the first episode
and it did not disappoint now if you
missed my breakdown of it you can check
it out in the link up above and if you
have not seen
one division episode 6 yet this is your
spoiler alert we will be diving into
some one division
episode 6 spoilers and really kind of
any episode before as well
so for those of you with me still we
have the first
mutants in the marvel cinematic universe
and i'm actually not talking about
monica rambo's cells changing and her
kind of mutating if you will although we
are definitely talking about that
it's a very important part of this video
but wanda literally created
two mutants billy and tommy and if
you're thinking this
isn't really that big of a deal well it
is and i'll tell you why
now kevin feige at 2019's
san diego comic con said that the
mutants and the x-men are coming to the
mcu
and we all pretty much thought that
there was going to be something big that
happened that kind of activated the x
gene in some people which is what we're
going to talk about
in this video in just a little bit but i
don't think many people expected the
very first
mutants in the mcu to actually be born
mutants which is what we get with billy
and tommy as we just saw in one division
episode 6 billy and tommy do
have powers and they were born with
these powers unlike their mother
who was given powers or had her powers
activated by the mind stone
now wanda could have had the x gene
inside of her and the mind stone could
have awoken it and activated it or the
mind stone could have simply altered her
dna somehow
and that could have given her her powers
more on this when we talk about the x
gene being activated but the point i'm
trying to make is that wanda was not
naturally born
with powers however her two children
are they have powers they have powers
just like they have in the comics in the
comics billy and tommy are the
superheroes wiccan
and speed and their powers are pretty
much the same that we saw in monovision
episode six
speed obviously has the powers of his
uncle he can run super fast and
wiccan has the abilities of his mother
so we see tommy running around
at super speed his uncle quick silver
and his mother wanda are super excited
to see that he has powers and later on
billy exhibits that he has powers as
well
now this is actually a monumental moment
in the marvel cinematic universe as
billy and tommy are the first
people ever to be born with super powers
that are human at least we're not
counting thor because he's actually a
god
billy and tommy are humans born with
superpowers think about it
everybody else was given power somehow
steve threw the serum hulk through the
serum wanda and petro through an
infinity stone captain marvel threw an
infinity stone as well
you get my point they were both born
with the genetic makeup of
mutants now obviously their powers came
from their mother's genetic makeup
which is altered because billy has the
powers of his mom and tommy has the
powers of his
uncle same dna same altered dna but a
big question
is who is their father it can't be
vision he's a synthesis he's not a human
and this will be a big question moving
forward but for now we can't really
answer it
now as i mentioned other people may have
mutant genes inside of them
that may be awakened but we've learned
from one of vision that her
energy actually changes people's cells
so for the others who aren't lucky
enough to have wanda as a mom
how do they come about how do the other
mutants get their ex gene activated
well this is by wanda's energy hex
barrier and let's take a deep dive into
how exactly the mutants will be
actually created in the mcu cosmic
microwave background radiation or cmbr
for short
is the energy that darcy said was being
picked up from inside of the hex then we
get a different variation of this
definition of cmbr from hayward when he
calls it
residual energy left over from the big
bang
now the energy they are referring to is
energy from the infinity stones
wong in avengers infinity war explains
that the big bang
actually sent the stones into existence
in our universe
by the dawn of the universe there was
nothing
then big banks and
six elemental crystals huddling across
the virgin universe
these infinity stones each control an
essential aspect of existence
space reality
power soul
mind
and time
so residual energy from the big bang is
the infinity stones
and as we know the mine stone is in west
view or at least one to try to recreate
the mind stone
as we've seen in some of the trailers
but it looks like she failed as we also
see the mind stone explode and this is
that residual energy that is inside of
the hex now
this combined with wanda's own energy
which is partly the same energy of the
mind stone because that's how her and
pedro got their powers
but this combined with her actual chaos
magic energy
is how the mutants the people with that
x gene are going to have that x gene
awakened
and we literally saw this happen in one
division episode vi
monica was explaining to jimmy and darcy
that she wants to go
back inside of the hex and try to help
wanda but darcy says that she can't go
back
in because the energy inside is
literally changing her cells
and it says it is literally changing her
this
is by far the biggest easter egg that
marvel studios has given us for the
mutants so far
as we know monica rambo in the comics is
the hero
photon and although she gets her powers
in a different way in the comics it
looks like she's going to be
a mutant in the mcu and that's how she
gets her powers through wanda's hex
energy which again is part infinity
stone energy
and this is how other people are going
to get their powers as well and have
that x gene awakened in them
and i believe that by the end of one
division wanda's
hex energy is going to cover the whole
world or at least a very big part of it
and it will create mutants by altering
human genetics or it will awaken the x
gene in some people
now this could also introduce the
inhumans to the marvel cinematic
universe
we know that marvel wants them in the
mcu there was supposed to be an
inhumans movie in phase 3 but
unfortunately that got scrapped and we
got the tv show instead
kevin feige has expressed interest in
bringing the inhumans back to the
mcu and if we have this huge energy
going through
most of the earth and it's changing
people's cells perhaps the inhumans
could be born the inhumans aren't that
different from mutants
except for instead of being born with
that mutant x
gene they gain their special powers when
exposed to terrigen
mists so perhaps this exposure to the
power of the infinity stones is combined
with terrigen mist somehow
the inhumans could be born and the
inhumans twitter account just tweeted
for the first time in
years this could be a little bit of a
teaser as to what's to come in the
future of the mcu
it's looking like some people exposed to
this energy are going to indeed be
inhumans now maybe marvel is going to
switch up the x gene just a little bit
maybe somebody doesn't have to be born
with it but perhaps the energy from the
infinity stones could actually literally
change their dna
to have the gene this is what darcy was
saying is happening to monica rambo her
cells are literally changing and
she's changing and we know she's going
to get super powers from this
just like wanda and pietro and just like
captain marvel and wanda has already
expanded her hex
and not just by a little bit but it
looks like she expanded it by at least
one or two miles perhaps even more and
it didn't really look like it was that
hard for her to do
so in upcoming one division episode she
could cover the entire earth with this
in an attempt to keep
everybody under her control so she can
keep her perfect life with her kids
and vision now once people's mutant
genes have been activated and they are
mutants from there these people will
have children and their kids should in
theory be born with
natural powers like billy and tommy and
that's how the mutant race
remains in the marvel cinematic universe
there's a lot more big reveals of wanda
vision coming very soon so be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of my latest breakdowns and
theories don't forget to like the video
and let me know what you thought about
it in the comments down below
for live updates on the mcu you can
follow me on instagram and twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching
woof
you